you auditioned for Twilight I did why
didn't you get that I would think you'd
be good for that I didn't really know
what it was when you audition when
you're like you know like a
run-of-the-mill act you know we're all
auditioning for all sorts of things you
just get like five pages yeah and and
then they're like act monkey when it
came out I was like hot damn right whoa
yeah were you jealous that um you
weren't in that movie just as an actress
no the only thing Emma Stone and I
actually had this conversation once
because we used to I'd always audition
for the same thing
um which now seems silly but
um she she got one thing that I was
dying for but the one thing that really
killed me like the only time I've ever
been truly devastated by losing an
audition because most of the time you're
like ah wasn't meant to be move on what
can you do was at Tim Burton's Alice in
Wonderland uh that one devastated me did
you go see it I yeah as soon as it came
out yeah yeah and when you were like oh
and she was perfect and amazing and I
couldn't have had a British accent and
yeah oh wow that that's a tough thing
yeah when you got in Hunger Games and
you knew it was going to be big was that
like consciously like I need a Twilight
I want that level of hit movie no
because I was kind of I had such a solid
Indie career at that point that I was
like this is perfect I get to act and
I'm not
that famous like I can that was what was
nice about the the sitcom I was just
getting checks right acting having fun
no
that Hunger Games would uh Typecast you
that you wouldn't get yeah yeah I mean I
knew it was going to be a life changer I
knew yeah
um and then in the other fear was yeah
only being known for that character but
that's a testament to your acting
because you've been able to do Hunger
Games and then get these other roles no
well it's true